another one
of these vaccine
mandate nerdwells
is rand paul
from kentucky
ostensibly a man of medicine an
ophthalmologist although not board
certified he created his own
licensing
organization to license himself
these people he took to a video to
explain
in a very uh aggressive manner how he
will not be bossed around
you're not the boss of me nancy pelosi
watch this
it's time for us to resist they can't
arrest all of us they can't keep all of
your kids home from school
it starts off in grand fashion they
can't kill all of us they can't arrest
all of us
they can't persecute all of us
this is what this has boiled down to for
these types
rand paul who has absolutely uh
eradicated any credibility he once had
if he had any at all he has become an
absolute trump lackey a trump automaton
he's a a facsimile
of donald trump
especially related to this particular
topic we will unfortunately let him
continue they can't keep every
government building closed
there's a few i would like to close
closed or might ought to keep closed
we don't have to accept the mandates
lockdowns and harmful policies of the
petty tyrants and bureaucrats we can
simply say no no petty tyrants and
bureaucrats petty
tyrants
to rand paul and many who follow him
they believe that a that a that a public
health measure to keep
children and the the infirmed people who
are especially vulnerable to infection
that keeping them safe and healthy is
tyranny
i would love to see a rand paul
put back in time
travel across the eons
to to a time when there were uh
revolutionary machinations
in in the colonies
and see how he would have stood up
there's a lot of talk about our founding
fathers risk their treasure
and their reputations and their sacred
honor
to enter into the revolution to free us
and make us independent from great
britain
is this does he have the medal for that
i say no
nancy pelosi you will not arrest or stop
me or anyone on my staff from doing our
jobs
we have either had coveted had the
vaccine or been offered the vaccine we
will make our own health choices we will
not show you a passport we will not wear
a mask we will not be forced into random
screenings and testings so you can all
this means is we will not care for our
fellow americans we will not be
concerned with the health and well-being
of our neighbors we don't care about
that
we're too busy owning the libs
i dare say rand paul's neighbor did not
go far enough
continue your drunk with power
reign over the capitol
president biden
we will not accept your agency's
mandates or your reported moves towards
a lockdown
no one should follow the cdc's
anti-science mask mandates and if you
want to shut down federal agencies again
some of which aren't even back to work
yet
i will stop every bill coming through
the senate with an amendment to cut
their funding if they don't come back to
work in person because this is pattern
and practice for rand paul
i'm gonna i'm gonna gum up the works
because that's all i'm good at
i'm gonna vote against this i'm going to
vote against amendments i'm going to
offer amendments that have no chance of
passage in order that i slow down the
mechanism of the senate to slow any
progress that might be made
in the course of uh signing legislation
into law by the president
unbelievable the temerity of this man
bureaucrats and union bosses we will not
allow you to do more harm to our
children again this year children are
not at any more risk from covid than
they are from the seasonal flu
with this
dr drew over here
we are witnessing a massive spike in
infections of children
of hospitalization of children
and he stands here
purporting to care about kids
while doing everything in his power
to ensure that those spikes only
increase
that we see more death more destruction
more mayhem at the hands of the virus
getting a little assist from republican
politicians everywhere every adult who
works in schools has either had the
vaccine or had their chance to get
vaccinated there is no reason for mask
mandates part-time schools or any
lockdown measures
children are falling behind in school
and are being harmed physically and
psychologically by the tactics that you
have used to keep them from the
classroom during the last year we won't
allow it again
if a school system attempts to keep
children from full-time in-person school
i will hold up every bill with two
amendments one to defund them and
another to allow parents the choice of
where the money goes for their child's
education do i sound fed up to you
that's because i am i'm not a career
politician
[Laughter]
oh come on rand paul
you can do better than that brother i'm
not a career politician
since when guy you've been in the senate
a long time you've been in government a
long time i don't see you stepping away
to go work on eyes anytime soon you're
absolutely a career politician who again
your only move your go to is to threaten
to gum up the works to threaten
obstructionism that's all you got
you're a reactionary ghoul
watching millions
of americans get the virus hundreds of
thousands of them die
we don't know where the ceiling of death
is in this country
and the reason we don't know the reason
we cannot estimate is because of
monsters like you
ghouls
like you
one of our sponsors is blue blocks blue
light glasses i've sometimes had issues
falling asleep at night eventually
realize some of it might be coming from
the blue light emitted by my phone and
computer screens peer-reviewed studies
show blue light can suppress the hormone
melatonin which can make it hard to fall
asleep because your sleep rhythms are
disturbed i've seen a lot of improvement
since i started using blue light glasses
from blue blocks most companies make
blue light glasses in a mass-produced
way with no quality standards but blue
blocks glasses are made in actual optics
labs in their australian headquarters
they have over 40 modern frames you can
choose from they have a prescription
version non-prescription even reading
glasses and for every pair of glasses
blue block cells they give a pair of
reading glasses to someone in need
you'll get 20 off when you go to
blueblocks.com
pacman the link is right underneath the
video and there's also free shipping
worldwide on orders over 115 dollars